In this class you have built your own framework and also used an existing one.
But when you enter the workforce and
work on projects, how do you know when to use which?
It's a common problem that you're going to be faced with.
So, let's see if Jacques has any advice for us.
>> Hey so there's actually a bit of a trade off in between using
an established framework like Bootstrap or using your own framework.
And when you use a framework like Bootstrap,
you're going to get a lot of features.
I mean, as you can see, you know, as you've worked through so
far, you can build a tremendous amount with Bootstrap.
When you start to need to do things outside of that framework,
when you want to start doing things that Bootstrap doesn't,
support, you might look at making your own.
And when you make your own you get a lot of freedom.
You, you can do anything really.
But you're going to have to put in the work to do it.
So as you approach your projects try and
see what that, how that breaks down for you.
If you're going to need to do a lot of things that Bootstrap doesn't support,
try looking at maybe rolling your own.
If you're going to be doing things that Bootstrap does or that another
framework does that you find that you really like, go for that, absolutely.
At Udacity we actually use a combination between Bootstrap and
some stuff that we've written ourselves, to work, alongside of it.
And that's pretty much it.
Congratulations on, you know, getting through, the class so far.
And you know, it'd be fantastic to see you working on your own projects,
or in you know, at some point a professional office like this.
[NOISE]